good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight you are watching the
free speech channel that's what it is
the last one left
for the next hour we're going to say
exactly what we believe is true
period it's still america the first
point to make an obvious point that has
now been banned as a thought crime in
the rest of the media
is that the united states government
should never under any
circumstances favor one race of people
over any other race of people
period that is immoral we are all
citizens we're all human beings we're
all created by god we are all equal
every one of us has a right to equal
treatment by our government
that right is guaranteed by our
constitution it's the heart of countless
laws
passed with well-deserved fanfare by our
congress over many decades
that right is inscribed on a monument on
our national mall to the reverend martin
luther king jr
who would be shocked and disgusted if he
watched susan rice on television today
susan rice is joe biden's chief domestic
policy adviser rice is in charge of
changing our country to conform to the
orthodoxies of the democratic party
how does susan rice plan to do that well
going forward she announced this
afternoon
quote every agency in the u.s government
a government that is by the way the
largest and most lavishly funded
organization in human history
every one of them will quote place
equity at the core of its policy design
specifically and for the benefit of
quote marginalized communities
now susan rice's speech was carried live
by many news outlets but as far as we
know
not a single one of them paused to ask
what exactly she was talking about
and they should have the federal
government is above all an enormous
printing press it manufactures
u.s currency it dispenses trillions of
dollars every year
according to rice much of that money
will now be distributed on the basis of
equity that means we'll go to people who
do not possess
quote privilege so let's get very
specific about what that means
what precisely is privilege can
privilege be measured
if so how exactly are we measuring it
can we see the privilege formula
we should see it because a huge amount
turns on the definition of this word
some americans won't get jobs because
it's been decided they have too much
privilege others won't get into college
or get promoted or win federal contracts
others will see their neighborhoods
change dramatically in ways they may not
like
because of their privilege they'll tell
you that's not true
but it is true and before any of that
happens the rest of us deserve a clear
explanation
of what's going on who's getting
rewarded who's getting punished
and why we don't have to ask politely
we're american citizens
this is our government no matter who we
voted for we're paying for it
so we can demand an answer but of course
there isn't
an answer that's the point they can't
really define privilege
they can't tell us who in a country with
no majority culture
actually qualifies as a quote minority
they don't want to have this
conversation in the first place
at all because their views are
indefensible
that's where they're general rather than
precise that's why they're trying to
make us
be quiet you see those efforts all
around you now never in american history
has there been press censorship on this
scale
as we noted at the top fox news is the
last significant media
organization remaining in this country
that allows its employees to tell
obvious truths in public the rest of
them have been muzzled or shut down
completely
the last to go is the social media site
parlor which was created as a free
speech alternative to the silicon valley
monopolies like twitter and facebook
a few weeks ago those very same
monopolies pulled it right off the
internet
parlor no longer exists when the history
of this period is written
the destruction of parliament will get
its own chapter and so will these people
the mindless corporate shills who
applauded its destruction
parlor has zero moderation the whole
point is that this is a completely free
community
that you could say what you want what it
tends to have done is attracted
very hard right conservatives conspiracy
theorists
racists um it's garbage i mean the stuff
on tw on parlor is is
is remarkable garbage oh the stuff on
parlor is remarkable garbage announces
some low iq thug on television
therefore it's totally fine virtuous in
fact
for amazon web services the largest
internet hosting service in the world
to simply unplug it to destroy it with
no debate or even coherent explanation
for why they did it
why did amazon do that it wasn't because
they were
morally offended by parlor that can't be
true
last year according to the group parents
together a total of 69 million
photos and videos of children being
sexually abused or reported to the
national center for missing and
exploited children
yet only eight of those reports came
from amazon web services
which was hosting quite a few of them
why is that
apparently jeff bezos didn't consider
sexual abuse videos garbage
as a director of parents together put it
quote amazon web services has vast
resources controls a third of cloud
infrastructure services
and handles billions of uploads and
downloads their abysmal failure to
report
child sex abuse material makes it clear
they're not looking for it
and of course they're not looking for it
whatever you think of kitty porn it's
not like it's right of center politics
so jeff bezos doesn't need to censor it
we should also tell you that amazon web
services provides hosting services to
twitter
and according to a new lawsuit twitter
quote benefited from and neglected to
remove
an exploited video featuring a minor boy
and another miner which was retweeted
thousands of times and received at least
160
000 views on its platform on twitter
the lawsuit says that the miner and his
mother repeatedly asked twitter to take
down
the video the sex abuse video but
twitter refused to do so
until the department of homeland
security intervened that's what it took
you're getting the picture there's a lot
of quote garbage floating around on
amazon web services and on twitter
but according to our media class none of
it would justify
shutting down amazon web services
incidentally you should also know that
amazon web services provides web
services for the
cia you're paying for it amazon has
built data centers in china
according to a report by the horizon
advisory group amazon runs a quote
innovation center in close partnership
with the communist party of china
it's not clear what they're innovating
but whatever it is it's not a problem
for our leaders because
no one in the chinese government voted
for donald trump it's not like they're
dangerous
but you know who is dangerous any
american citizen who doesn't agree with
msnbc
watch the whole idea of prevention needs
to be examined by the new congress what
do i mean by that
we still don't have a domestic terrorism
law we still don't treat this like we do
international terrorism change the
religion of some of those people
that entered the capital and you've got
violent jihadists
you've got the fbi with undercover
informants electronic surveillance
and agents in their groups and
organizations because we've designated
them as potentially violent
we've got nothing like that going on
oh so the government should change
the religion of those people the
government now has the right to change
your religion according to the g-man on
tv
that's a big change when did this become
a theocracy
the rest of thought we are allowed to
believe any religion we wanted to
believe
even ones that mourning joe doesn't
understand or approve of
we imagine that was the whole point of
america
not anymore equity and inclusion means
that you will believe what they tell you
to believe
period or else you're a terrorist and
they can hurt you because we hurt
terrorists
listen to america's new grand inquisitor
adam schiff of california
we have been urging for some time that
the fbi and the department of homeland
security
raise the priority to domestic terrorism
to white nationalism as it threatens the
country
and we're going to continue sounding the
alarm and make sure that they're
devoting the resources the time the
attention
uh just as we did after 9 11 to the
threat from international terrorism
we need to give the same priority and
urgency to domestic terrorism
got that vote the wrong way and you are
a jihadi you thought you're an american
citizen with rights and just a different
view but no you're a jihadi
and we're going to treat you the way we
treated those radicals after 9 11 the
way we treated bin laden get in line pal
this is a war on terror
keep in mind as you listen to people
talk like this adam schiff is far from
the only one keep in mind
they're talking about american citizens
here they're talking about you
but nobody seems to notice or care one
who does notice and cares quite a bit
one of the only democrats willing to
stand up and oppose
this transparently fascist purge that's
what it is
is tulsi gabbard the former member of
congress from hawaii gabbard published
a video message today explaining exactly
what's at stake
the john brennans adam shifts and the
oligarchs in big tech who are trying to
undermine our constitutionally protected
rights
and turn our country into a police state
with kgb style surveillance
are also domestic enemies and much more
powerful
and therefore dangerous than the mob
that stormed the capital
what you just heard her say is true
no matter what they tell you no matter
how much they attack the person who said
it oh she's a tool of assad
it's absolutely true that is true and
god blessed helsi gabbard for saying so
out loud